[Musique]
lesquels vont rose le maire de sète
lucette dans son caddie ce matin dans
nos studios ici à la tour lu mine alors
qu'ils auraient dû qu'il aurait pu être
à paris avec d'autres de ses collègues
en compagnie du président de la
république dans le cadre du grand débat
national bonjour nekkaz morose bonjour
et bienvenue jours avant vos auditeurs
et auditrices pourquoi n'êtes vous pas
aller à paris jauzion nous avons reçu
une invitation évidemment comme
l'ensemble des maires de l'aude première
nous n'avons pas jugé bon de répondre à
cette invitation d'une part parce qu
elle arrivait buts allemands il ça me
donne l'impression que le président par
politesse pour ne pas être accusé
d'avoir oublié de l'oublier l'outre-mer
vite elle est maire et d'autre part et
c'est assez le fondamental il nous
semble bien que après avoir écouté la
ministre de l'outre-mer donc la parole
du gouvernement que le jeu était très
encadré on nous disait oui mais tout
l'outre-mer il y a eu les assises de
l'autre mais auparavant il ya eu les
états généraux
donc apparemment il n'y avait plus rien
à redire spécifiquement sur l'outre-mer
qui avait le débat national auquel nous
pouvions participer donc nous avons
pensé que qu'il y ait du travail à faire
au niveau de notre commune et qu' il ya
des mères qui s'y sont rendus et très
bien bien bien à eux mais nous ne
pensions pas qu'il était indispensable
que nous et que nous nous y rendions à
guetter nicaise moreau skins arc les
contradictions de la part des élus
version 2015 2019 tout le monde prône la
démocratie participative tout le monde
prône des échanges et puis au moment où
on a l'occasion de rencontrer le plus
aux politiques le président de la
république bat on n'y va pas la
démocratie question d'ego c'est ça la
démocratie participative ça n'a rien à
voir avec une rencontre entre les maires
et le président de la république ça a à
voir avec l'implication des citoyens
dans la vie publique
oui mais les lmr ce sont des
représentants de ces citroyens vous êtes
les élus quand même les plus proches de
la population l'occasion d'aller dire
emmanuel macron peut-être qu'il se
trompe dans son insolite ici la
démocratie représentative est pas là
principe participatif activement les
maires le prix de la république donne le
sentiment de vouloir s'appuyer sur les
corps intermédiaires notamment les
maires très bien pendant quelques temps
il a plutôt donné l'impression du
contraire
donc aujourd'hui vous voulez vous ne
voulez pas être vous nicaise morose
mr relais du message présidentiel et
vous ne voulez pas non plus être maire
tampon entre ce président là et la
population qui souffre pas du tout notre
absence à paris ce n'est une défiance
d'une contestation c'est simplement une
question d'efficacité nous voulons
effectivement nos payes tampon mais être
le relais de notre population par
rapport à la politique publique menée
pour elle et pour lui permettre de se
développer mais nous pensons pas que
aller dans un cadre et prix encadrés ça
soit très efficace et surtout qu'on nous
dit qu'il y a eu les assises de
l'outre-mer très bien il ya eu les
assises de l'outre-mer et on nous a
demandé à ce moment-là de présenter la
demande et aux martiniquais
guadeloupéens autres outre habitants
dont le premier de travailler sur des
projets ce qu'ils ont fait bon
maintenant on nous dit que ce sont ces
deux là seront développés elle serait
bien on les attend dans le développement
de ses projets puis nous entendons
véritablement le le début que le
gouvernement déploie sa politique pour
l'outre-mer de thèmes qui seront centre
au cours de ces échanges la vie chère et
l'emploi au moment où une loi
consommation vendre une idée hausse
sensible sur certains produits en tous
cas dans l'hexagone ne peut être un peu
plus tard chez nous au moment où
l'aspect psychologique de la baisse du
montant affiché sur les feuilles de paye
selon de plus en plus visible pour pour
la population
on a bien compris que vous n'êtes pas
convaincu par la démarche de manuel
macro mais vous ne pouvez pas rester les
bras croisés alors aujourd'hui quel est
le champ d'action possible pour le maire
comme vous alors la vie chère c'est pas
un débat récent chez nous c'est un débat
de toujours et on n'a pas le sentiment
que les et que les gouvernements
successifs prennent la mesure du
problème de la problématique outre mer
par exemple il ya il ya une
réglementation qui existe sur les les
positions dominantes
nous n'avons pas le sentiment que les
gouvernements successifs appliquent ou
saas règne à appliquer cette
réglementation nous avons plutôt le
sentiment du contraire ce gentil
l'occasion magnifique de le rappeler au
président de la république oui mais il
le sait vous croyez vous voyez de la
besoin de moi pour le savoir ça il a dit
voilà ici c'est administratifs sont là
c'est simon représentant de son de
l'administration des potes de concentrer
son là il n'a pas besoin de moi pour
savoir ça simplement ce que moi en tant
que représentant d'une des populations
de martinique et la communauté du ciel à
dire c'est qu'il serait temps que ces
gouvernants qu'ils soient actuels ou
passés et futurs lier points et prennent
en compte véritablement là l'importance
de cette question là pour nous les
positions dominantes sur une petite île
comme la note qu'une petite économistes
comme la note sans étouffante pour
l'économie et c'est ce que nous vivons
les positions dominantes empêche
l'initiative les positions dominantes
empêche nice a vu des gens et ce qui
m'intéresse et l'initiative des gens
d'ici
on sent bien que l'ia comme comme
quelque chose une allusion à la
plantation de territoire de centre
commercial sur notre territoire
pas seulement sur nos territoires il y a
je fait clairement allusion à la à tous
tout le développement économique qu'on
propose sous la martinique je fait
clairement allusion allusion aux doigts
économique qui s'applique à ce pays qui
ne permet pas aux gens d'ici doit
s'exprimer économiquement alors 2009 il
ya dix ans nous a donné notre grogne
sociale d'envergure ici on a entendu des
revendications tout azimut des réponses
ont été menées par les citoyens
eux-mêmes parfois mieux produire
produire local consommer local organisé
structuré look à la limite en dehors des
systèmes classiques que nous connaissons
pourquoi nous n'avons pas été capables
de le faire de façon beaucoup plus
massive à l'échelle de notre territoire
je me pose la question comme vous je
n'ai pas la réponse
depuis 2009 effectivement les gens se
sentent exclus et voilà un exemple de
démocratie participative
les gens se sont exprimés depuis qu'est
ce qui s'est passé et rien depuis au
contraire on est allé encore plus loin
dans ce que les gens dénoncé oui mais on
a quand même vu par exemple des multi ce
n'est peut-être qu'un exemple des
multiplication d'initiatives comme par
exemple jardin créole comment mieux
développer son petit jardin créole n'a
eu des coups de main sont multipliées
oui je vous êtes dans le secteur de la
vente par geslin secteur que je connais
bien culture parce qu'il faut nourrir sa
population et moi de le lire mais ces
initiatives de jardin que c'est purement
anecdotique
oui le le crs à ce stade anecdotique
c'est ça qu'ils nommaient pourquoi ce
rsa ce stade-là la politique publique
pour l'agriculture ne va pas dans ce
sens là alors c'est anecdotique on a
l'impression que on nous amuse avec ça
mais la politique publique ne va pas
dans le sens de la production pour le
marché local mais regardez les chiffres
c'est tout vous regardez où l'état mais
l'argent son argent et l'argent de
l'europe
et puis c'est tout mais voilà il faut à
10 voitures actuelles développé que tu
émulation la table par exemple pour
multiplier ça va faire encore un exemple
dans le s'étonne que vous connaissez
bien
mais lui aurait pu avoir davantage de
coopérative qui fonctionne mieux pour
mieux se déversaient qu'il n'y a pas
davantage de coopérative ça c'est un
leurre je n'ai pas parce qu'il n'y a pas
davantage de coopérative qu'il n'y a pas
de production c'est parce qu'il n'y a
pas davantage de producteurs et
d'exploitations agricoles et la
politique publique ne vise pas à
conforter à consolider les exploitations
agricoles dans leurs multitudes de leur
multiplicité la politique publique vise
à concentrer autour de certains faux
dieux de certaines exploitations c'est
ça la réalité
votre collègue du prêcheur marque solène
ados
fait son credo dans sa commune du
prêcheur de cette démocratie
participative des parties se sont créés
par exemple sur ce modèle on se souvient
de martigues citoyenne par exemple des
candidats aux futures élections
municipales 2020 multiplient les accords
pour rédiger un programme finalement je
reviens cette question lorsque vous n'y
allez pas paris est ce que vous n'êtes
pas hors du coup non mais il faut pas
qu'on limite notre vie à aller ou pas à
paris il ya beaucoup de choses qui se
passent ici beaucoup de décisions que
nous prenons ici qui impacte notre vie
quotidienne
paris c'est une chose mais fort de
france aussi il s'en est une autre
la martinique c'est une chose les
décisions que nous prenons chacun à
notre niveau impact il faut pas l'idée
que c'est toujours la faute de l'autre
qu'il faut qu'on abandonne à nous aussi
nous impacte notre vie quotidienne très
en tant que maire confronté à la réalité
au plus proche des gens vous aimeriez
sortir quoi du chapeau du magicien pour
votre mission au quotidien
vous parliez de politique citoyenne je
vous rappelle que nous sommes élus sans
étiquette sur la bannière citoyenne nous
avons été élus a tant que citoyen du
cerf nous avons et nous développant une
politique qui consiste à consulter la
population à chaque fois que nous
proposons un projet qui va modifier le
rythme ou le développement de la commune
de sainte luce et nous faisons des
réunions publiques
nous impliquons les gens nous le
questionnement sur ce que nous proposons
donc nous pratiquons la police mais vous
êtes limité avec les moyens financiers
par exemple qu'est ce que vous pouvez
faire face à la crise sociale la misère
qui kiffent a pas beaucoup de familles à
cette lutte comme ailleurs en martinique
nous apportons l'aide que nous pouvons
nous réformons par exemple vous parlez
du social nous avons réformé notre
manière d'intervenir au niveau social en
faisant en sorte que les familles se
sont accompagnées et non pas seulement
aidé financièrement et nous essayons
d'accompagner les hommes et évidemment
il
le soutien social dépasse le pouvoir
d'une commune en terme de l'intervention
financière mais nous participons à omaha
la martinique
de manière globale et dans ce domaine là
comme dans d'autres nous avons à prendre
des décisions nous au niveau de la
martinique pour accompagner mieux encore
notre population ces conditions de faire
un autre petit nouveau de la commune de
sainte lucie caisse bourreuse est-ce que
vous suivrez quand même les débats qui
seront relayées sur les antennes de la
première dès 9h30 ce matin sexualité
partiellement par curiosité nous nous
serons attentifs à ce qui sera dit et
j'espère que ceux qui y sont ils y sont
je n'ai aucun reproche à leur faire bien
au contraire
j'espère qu'ils arriveront à ouvrir un
peu la boîte pour aller au delà de ce
qui a toujours été dit et enfin l'entrée
dans dans une concrétisation il faut
prendre quelques sujets bien précis et
les travailler et faire en sorte que
nous puissions aboutir on n'a pas le
temps ce matin on aurait pu en donner
quelques exemples
merci des caisses morose merde cette
leçon rappelle le rendez-vous pour nos
auditeurs nos téléspectateurs et ceux
qui nous suivent sur internet et 9h30 à
partir de 9h30 ce matin sur les ondes de
la première merci seront reversés
avec nous ce matin dans son caddie bonne
journée
[Musique]
donc